Nick Jonas is dating a lily collins and
EG has exclusive details on the
blossoming romance
23 year old singer has a new lady in his
life
a 26 year old actress Lily Collins she's
also Falcone's daughter a source tells
Edie quote they've been hanging out it's
really new they're both into each other
the new couple has definitely been
hanging out and traveling together last
week they ventured up to Mammoth for a
mini getaway one fan snapped this photo
would make at Schatz bakery and bishop
just outside of the snowy hotspot for
friend joked on social media not to
forget to mention in Lily's presence I
do live a public life and for whatever
reason people are interested in that
make was most recently linked to beat
Hudson though both stars played coy
about the romance rumors here's what she
told et last month great you're not
gonna tell I think you talk about Halle
much not after he sees you in this dress
hey guys what do you think of Nick and
Lily do you like them together or not so
much send me all your thoughts over on
Twitter and bye for now